hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome at long last back - oh it's
a golf don't escape for that's it don't
escape for No don't escape for days in
the wasteland alright you get me here
you feelin me okay good I have been away
I've been far away from home and things
have been very sporadic but I am back
and I played this guy's dead
woohoo you oh he was dead before so I
guess it's okay now are you sure you
don't want to go no we need to do now if
I remember how to play which I know I do
where's my map how do I get my map we
had a dream I've dreamed a dream or no
oh wait
Oh once again I survived that night here
we go I had another dream we were
attacked by a group of thugs bandits
raided the hideout and started shooting
they didn't want to leave anyone alive
Kate wants us to go to the sidereel
plexus office and look for a spaceship
location things done yesterday that may
help I have a rifle to defend myself
against the attackers we have to protect
ourselves from the thugs alright alright
ok I think there's something that we can
do hey listen everybody shut up you're
all screaming you're all panicking about
nothing that's right I can't get to the
map unless I go here hi sidereal Plexus
office how much gas do we got do we have
enough do we have everything that we
need we need to get to the truck the
truck was at the roadblock okay so
that's the first and foremost thing
alright guys I'm feeling it out just let
me let me feel myself for a look no the
truck was not here was it drunk up there
that's right the truck here okay truck
is here we've got gas we've got all
these coats that we do not need I can
bring those back to the base to drop off
some stuff because I didn't know if I
was gonna need it and turns out I
actually do not need it that is a fact
right me that's a fact so we're gonna go
back to the house and save a lot of time
even though he just wasted ten minutes
that's okay cuz who needed ten minutes
anyway not me that's for damn sure
oh [ __ ] did I leave the door open no
that's probably not good that's probably
fine definitely no one's in here
anyway I'm gonna put this [ __ ] away I
don't need this I know for a fact I
don't need it what is this a bandage
probably don't need it the nails I could
probably keep here just because I'm
gonna need them over here the metal bars
are good
oh it's bandits probably can't do good
with metal bars it's a fax if you know
bandits they can't do [ __ ] against metal
bars okay i'ma lead us here so don't
think I'm gonna need it with me um I'll
bring the tools just because I don't
know what's gonna help me get this [ __ ]
done it's been I can't believe it's been
weeks since I played this game like I
really like this game and I really enjoy
it and I really like what it's got going
on but man I'm just an idiot for not
being around and planning ahead and
actually think no I have an excuse
that's right I got sick and that's what
happened let me put the propane in here
cuz I don't think I'm gonna need that
let's go for it I guess locking isn't
nearly as important as it is at the end
of the day so let's just hop in the
truck and let's go see what the dealio
is about the new sidereel plexus office
good thing is we got the fuel-efficient
car and we have the bridge all fixed up
so everything is still gonna be real
fast for us so let's just jet on over
there the city didn't survive even the
first weeks after the apocalypse hit by
earthquakes it was quickly abandoned
only to be swallowed by sands after the
climate changed I never liked the idea
of going there it was like a massive
tombstone emerging from the wasteland
luring travelers so it could become a
grave for more victims if this was the
place we had to go oh it's the place any
questions uh yeah this isn't the outpost
you were looking for right have you been
listening to me at all no not at all of
course this isn't the outpost I was
looking for that one I had a launch pad
and a spaceship you dummy
Oh silly me I dig this one well this is
an office all right what exactly are we
looking for here coordinates we need to
know where the launch pad outpost is
located look for any documents or maps
you can find it's gotta be somewhere
here all right what are your connections
with sidereal plexus don't know what you
mean well how did you know about the
spaceship thing in the first place we
have this conversation another time
it's a long story I mean we got plenty
of time
all right let's move on then did these
all go to the same place is this all
part of the same thing okay
right well here we go then I suppose
it's fine we arrived at the sidereal
Plexus office in this destroyed city
gate hopes to find the location of the
spaceship somewhere around here all
right well good freaking luck there's no
way to get in didn't there be a door
here there is it's probably a few feet
underdahl that's and we could bring a
shovel and you serious digging a deserts
worth the sand would take us hours no
time for that let's look for another way
and hey hey listen come on now how about
you let me just let means I can't see
how that would work we just talked about
how work yeah whatever alright let's go
up the big sand dune everybody follow me
I'm sure it's fine all right no one's
following me all the ones oh you want to
climb up the sand dune this action will
take five minutes hey sure why not
I wasted five minutes are oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] moons
getting close oh yeah that looks good oh
yeah it's good really scenic like it
makes me think something Bad's gonna
happen
oh hi alright okay
what's it out you know you gonna watch
out or what oh [ __ ] wait a minute what
are you damn it it oh okay alright I'll
help sure you want to save Barry you
might not have enough time to save both
of your friends oh oh
the kids spry he can pull himself up
kids are crazy good climbers
[Music]
Cody Oh
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm sorry but oh no there's gotta be a
way I thought the kid would be able to
hold on I didn't know he was weakened
from but it knows four little limbs it
couldn't take the strain I knew it was
an ominous sequence for some reason they
didn't know guys you're judging me I
turned back the time clock I did my
Harry Potter time turner timmy turner
and i wished for a time redo alright I'm
gonna go to the restaurant first because
I remember there was something about the
bugs and how they're all dead now
maybe so I'm gonna go to the bug room
see it's open perfect now Cody and good
died here what's this oh this issue's
special report sad real plexuses coma
clinic is it a real legit clinic for
people in a prolonged comatose state or
perhaps it's something much more
sinister than that we had weekly
conspiracy believe there's something
more to it than meets the public eye so
let's take a closer look at the banker
corporation's newest investment read
more inside this issue sadly Alexis
doesn't have to be introduced to anyone
Oh blah blah blah a clinic for people in
comas if your loved one had a misfortune
of falling into a coma you might want to
some professional care for them usually
this kind of deal is expensive dirt
cheap course people point out there's PR
Sun an attempt to improve its image
while the entirely probably don't
believe it to be the truth cuz we all
know the truth is always hidden much
deeper some families that decide to use
the clinic and who wish to remain
anonymous to weekly conspiracy readers
report seeing their loved ones in public
walking around as if nothing had
happened
approached they don't even recognize
their family members displaying totally
different alien behavior well the wakeup
rate is people in comas is low in
general the
of coma patients behaving like
completely different people is unheard
of could it mean sad rail is using them
for scientific experimentation
brainwashing is one many one option but
we at weekly conspiracy have another
possible and chilling solution sidereal
plexus is working on some sort of mind
transfer technology they're using people
in comas vessels for other
consciousnesses not interested in the
well-being of the owner of the original
body they're just using them as sleeves
of sorts while this is totally
speculative and we lack the necessary
proof we have been contacted by supposed
former clinic worker who confirmed our
theory unfortunately all contact with
that person has since been lost we don't
know who they were and whether or not
they were being truthful we will
continue this topic in future issues of
weekly conspiracy so stay tuned and
remember they want you to think we're
the crazy ones well we're not crazy oh
sorry about that go by the way this room
is not sound treated at all I got no
foam here I put up a blanket see that
blanket that's what I did
I did all by myself wait so there was
that it Oh God oh close door yes yes
please a bottle of oil no it's not gonna
do for me a bottle of rat poison how's
it gonna help me stop Cody from falling
it was imminent doom I'm beginning to
suspect that it might not forgetting to
think that maybe I'm not gonna be able
to save nobody oh oh well nothing would
have changed here nothing would have
changed here right oh no you want to see
your dead wife again here [ __ ] all right
you know what let's just go there brick
I just freaked I I hate choices like
this boy well at least I want to hear
Cody's voice one more time before he
makes the plunge let's talk to him at
least
hey Barry how you doing hey listen if
you were dangling above a pan you know
what do you think of this place I didn't
go to the city too often mostly just
when Maggie needed something from here
and I had to give her a lift living so
close was kind of Handy it was quiet in
our area but when you needed something
who's only 20 minutes trip it changed a
lot let me just look at all this it's
even worse than anywhere else I wonder
what happened to all the people simple
they even moved out or
I'm buried in the sand are you worried
about tonight it's night I'm worried
about this whole SideReel plexus thing
that office isn't this is in the city
nobody lives or goes there now I have a
bad feeling about it
Wow oh come on something wrong with Cody
you're always looking at him think I
envy him he lost like everything without
family without friends without anyone he
knows with a group of strangers who
knows how long he was alone before you
found and you look at him smiling happy
and eager to play
he's with the world dying around him
listen bury all of this is cruelly
ironic right now so please stop making
me sad I wish I could be like that oh
you will any new thoughts on Kate I
don't know David the sidereal Plexus
thing she claims she didn't know where
it was but then she knows less you know
it's just so much about them not to
mention this whole spaceship idea isn't
this ridiculous okay hey Cody
hey how are you strong are your legs are
your bones have they formed in like
solid bones yet are they still flexible
I like I'm really wondering how cushiony
are you sure shoes are those Air Jordans
you got on there what do you think Cody
it's almost like a disaster movie one
time some other boys from the orphanage
wanted to watch this film about a huge
earthquake the whole city was devastated
it looked similar it's just more sand we
kind of are in a catastrophe right now
can I be the main hero and I will save
everyone at the end the roles already
taken kid uh-huh
you can be my sidekick yay oh no what is
it Cody worried about tonight yeah but
also do we have to go to that side
plexuses nothing office it sounds kind
of scary oh come on did you change your
opinion about Barry don't know he's
still sad it's not that easy to let go
after such a loss I know I'm trying to
cheer him up I think today I saw I'm
smiling people should smile more often
everything is better then oh yeah okay
when you put it that way it doesn't
sound too complicated course it doesn't
you make it complicated all adults do
any new thoughts on cake she's nice but
a bit scary how so like she's pretty but
also kind of mean but not really not
really yeah I think she's a good person
she just tries to hide it why would
anyone try to hide that they're a nice
person I don't get it
don'ts okay well doodlee do
[Music]
I've got a little I got a will guys rat
poison
wouldn't want that I would me first I
say oh no oh no what have we done what
have we done oh gods the mob marched yes
maybe if we'd a held off on getting
buried only one of them would have fell
and then you know right no guys wait
hang on I think we should rethink this
just a little bit what about that art as
I'm looking weird we arrived a desert
really okay okay this is the place any
questions no more questions hey which
one of these two who looks like they
have the strongest spine the most
cushiony buttocks I'm sorry I know you
guys would like stop being a [ __ ] and
just go for and I'm like I'm sorry but I
just you know okay all right there was
no like rope I didn't have like a rope
or anything right
there was no rope let me just all right
hand everybody indulge me we're just
gonna go back down just because I'm just
gonna check everywhere and then if
there's nothing else I'll just load up
the save where we're on the roof and I
guess I got a pic you know I guess I got
a pic we can't leave until we find what
we came for
listen Timmy Tim Tim Timmy damn Cody hey
Cody
listen old are you
[Music]
what if I just go in Oh God excuse me
Kody meri save them day they won't all
that much let me jump let me jump
let me jump you just wait well I'm
crippled with indecision and they're
looping through so I think it's okay
listen Kody I I gotta save you Kody I'm
sorry you couldn't survive that Oh God
I've emotionally distraught you're safe
calm down where's Barry I'm sorry I
couldn't grab both of you know why did
you say oh you wanted me to save you I
think he'd want to me to save you Kody
so it's my fault out no [ __ ] I cared
about you more than he cared about
himself oh [ __ ] that's not good and it
was terrible but we can't let him die
for nothing get to the opening I'll try
to find another way and find the
location of that base look for documents
or a map or some sort we'll just beat up
later okay thanks k all right Thank You
Kate hey there hey there how you doing
hey sick kid no I should have saved
Barry kids are spry you know Barry's
dead I couldn't save them all this chart
is some lives of different heights and
curves I have no idea what exactly it
represents I didn't have anything that I
could shoot him it's what I could do I
could hit him with the rock I don't like
being here can we leave already this
place is wrong it's evil can you feel it
well you know
kind of yeah it kind of can feel it
chewy oh yeah I don't like this I don't
like this at all completely collapse
fire alarm think I've done enough glass
breaking for now nope not for me hammer
that [ __ ]
alright whatever elevator door the
elevators stuck mid floor I don't think
getting inside would be a good idea you
don't know that alright fine I don't
like this place it's so dark in here
don't be scared Cody I'm not what was
that
I am scared I don't want to be here it's
okay I'm here we'll get what we came for
and then we'll just leave okay
I like it it's locked can I bash it open
that won't open okay fine whoa Oh dead
body he has an ID on his neck good
that's what I came for
not powered or it's broken or both oh
it's dork we evacuate to our designated
launch pad Adam EML do the map please
find an email entitled escape and open
the attachment in front of the building
three buses will be waiting for everyone
buses a and B are being prepared for
less important employees please ask for
seats in the coach marked with the
letter C departure at nine C is the only
bus that goes to the launch pad have
your ID cards with you this is super
important the crucial thing is to keep
calm and to follow orders the trip to
the mountains will take less than an
hour and the departure is scheduled for
12:00 from there you know what happens
next
the sleep process will take place right
after landing at the target location
remind yourself of any training
instructions you will need there's a
strict and complete ban on talking with
people from outside of the company do
not share information with colleagues
friends or family this will help us
avoid panic sharing any information is
permitted and excludes you from the
escape list there are only a few days
left in this world let's just keep it
quiet we do not want any hindrance at
the end other instructions will be
available on site including group
assignments and locations to which you
will be sent each of you will be briefed
about what happens so you can share this
information at the destination it is
very important crucial that we do not
repeat the same mistakes anywhere else
just remember the only way to escape is
to stop running
oh I don't know about that one chief
why would someone print that out or fax
it weird okay it's not powered or it's
broken or both just got old silencer a
gun silencer what is it doing here
maybe it's the reason there's a dead guy
at the desk assassins do you think
they're still here
no way come on Cody in the darkness
there is no way I don't like it I don't
like it I don't like being in the
darkest County run okay you didn't run
Cody but you know I appreciate the
hustle I should find the outpost
location before going any further mm-hmm
you spent some time upgrading the rifle
adding a silencer would make it possible
to shoot without drawing a lot of
attention let me hold off on that I
don't know if I'm gonna need that but
it's an interesting concept ID badge
right click to view sidereal Plexus
Jacob sallman unlucky guy oh yeah all
right so I gotta use this on this I've
unlocked it good
all right what do we got here bada bing
emergency power supply pin a equals 50
pin B equals 10 so a needs 50 B needs 10
so this is 10 and oh [ __ ] oh oh oh there
we go okay so 60 0 10 0 blank bada bing
65 what the [ __ ]
oh it's scratched out so that must be 15
so if I do negative 30 negative 30
instead 15 15 that's 65 15 50 okay so
then 10 whatever this is let's find out
how much is in here cuz that's zero so
we just need this to go to 10 and this
go here okay
good right no no no no no no no no I'm
pretty good right all right let's see
what's in the scary room Hey look o it's
things okay a working PC oh that's right
I said it was in an email marked escape
quert admin one interesting how's the
Internet where's porn gimme porn I want
that
give give to me eBay eBay leaves Jessica
is on leave so Human Resources your
responsibility for now visit natalie
stafford here's a list of people
visiting from world sp4
[Music]
a world as peaceful please take care of
our combination fire someone who knows
this miss an era when it comes to mr.
sampling he will be accompanied by
catherine and mayweather whoa she is our
new pilot please keep her on a
need-to-know basis only and do not
disclose any confidential information
it's not much time left
Catherine Mayweather pilot could that be
Kate we really need to have a talk also
about these whole world things Flagg
this email for breach of company policy
hey so as we talked during lunch we
should totally go hunting this weekend
I've got lodge a few miles outside of
town where I keep hunting guns and some
bear traps yeah yeah I know traps are
not perfectly legal but who cares right
it's a nice forest with lots of game to
chase check out the attached map if you
want to know I get there
Oh maybe worth checking out it marked it
on my map interesting
no mr. Douglas I will not go out to
dinner with you Catherine Mayweather
mm-hmm I could say I'm sorry but while I
don't know you I assumed you'd valid me
you me as a beautiful person except I
have to tell you I'm not really sorry
fair enough Kate reminder all employees
are required to submit a corporate
compliance report by the end of this
week to find the attached report and
fill it in after that please access
SideReel ago log into your account okay
interesting so yeah I've been working on
configuring the power output of the
backup battery on her floor as you know
it's a little bit makeshift now there's
no backup battery for the guys below us
but it's possible to rewire our battery
if needed just make sure to feed pin a
with 15 volts and pin B with 40 volts
okay um all right 15 40 got it easy
you better print it out or write it down
because once you start rewiring this
floor will be cut off from emergency
power not that it's likely to happen
though our grid is secure and will last
until the end of the world how about
going hunting this weekend
all right 15 40 God all right as you may
be unaware an unforeseen incident took
place on the surface of the Moon despite
the incident today's still a normal
working day please do not panic
additionally we would like to remind you
that you are legally obliged to the
company agreement to deny any
connections between the company and the
recent incident Oh easy is that good
great Oh Ari really important are we in
danger
no remain calm and proceed with your
duties the explosion on the moon poses
no direct or indirect threat to earth
and/or the company are we in danger
people say the moon is going to hit us
is it our fault or not I have my doubts
can you give us any more detail
as you may be aware an unforeseen
incident took place on the surface of
the Moon just by the incident today
still working it just along okay all
right
escape all VIP personnel and researchers
must evacuate immediately please find
the attached map of the launch pad
location in might be useful in case of
our transportation fails
mr. sampling if you're reading this one
of our employees was causing trouble by
spreading unsettling emails as requested
he has been disposed of that's it this
is the location we needed I marked on my
map now I can finally get out of here oh
well not yes okay Joshua simmer you
bastards you did it you thought nobody
would find out you've destroyed the
entire world you maniacs I'll make damn
sure every Police Department every
military organization everyone will
forcefully detain each and every one of
your workers on-site you are no
scientists who are all charlatans there
will be no place on earth for you to
hide Joshua Sumer sunrise telegram
that's fair fair's fair
and that sounds fair alright I learned
about the lodge in the woods up north it
might be worth checking out I found the
location of the outpost okay um what
happened nothing David do you think you
think Barry's alive I don't know kid I
hope he's okay me too I don't know 50
and 40 maybe maybe he mean he'd be
downstairs so I mean very unlikely 15
and 40 okay and that should be
downstairs power Oh redness all right
elevator door
I think it's see the bottom is too high
to jump okay fire hose locked into glass
cabinet well it's not gonna last up
against this I'm thinking I use the fire
hose too yeah that's what I thought
that's what I thought that's what I
thought it's what I thought
Oh is what I thought let's see about
this door seems to be locked from the
other side a pipe oh it's too heavy here
could give me a hand I bet if Barry was
alive he could help me hey there hey
Chum how you doing pal I can't fit in
there hey Corey
hey can you uh vent hey Cody do you
think he'd crawl through that vent over
there huh why because this door is
locked
maybe there's a way to open it from the
inside okay just wait here I'll open it
oh yeah
there's nothing here so just some office
stuff thanks Cody it's like whoa whoa
whoa whoa the year of the beginning in
the end you give me a zoom on that Wow
whoa
all right floppy disk a floppy disk
labeled the phase control light have no
idea what it is yet I feel it's really
important I definitely don't want to
leave this thing behind all right well
I'm kind of running out of space here
stack of papers all right oh patient
Nathan harvies the patient has recently
joined the travelers team with the first
training finished he was admitted to the
practical part promising results leave
control at a level sufficient enough to
visit other facilities in the near
future all right he's in good health and
all indicators are normal his mental
state is currently questionable the
patient feels strong anxiety after
waking up since the past few days he has
been experiencing the feeling of someone
else's someone's presence this is
probably due to the scene incident
during the last control dreaming he's a
testimony it was there almost for sure
it's stood in the shadow it was looking
at me I did not see it at first but I
felt it I couldn't move I wanted I tried
but I was paralyzed I was not even sure
if I was still asleep or awake then it
moved no train solutions helped I lost
control so that's probably reality right
if I couldn't do anything
must have been reality if so why was he
there I woke up after all
recommendations conducts psychiatric
tests again moved the patient away from
the dreamers for an indefinite period
prescribed sedatives the patient has
also made a sketch of an encounter
creature gross we got that so I'm
guessing if we had Barry we'd be able to
move that pipe oh yeah code your way to
go bud okay you want to climb down the
elevator shaft
yes let's see what's going on down here
[Music]
No Oh No Barry's gonna be all mangled I
need a key to open this door oh oh oh no
oh no oh [ __ ] ah Barry you're alive
looks like looks like my expectations
about this place have suddenly dropped
huh
you're terrible Elsa feel terrible what
should I do
you got the location of the base yeah
good
get out here then I can't leave you like
that I'm good it's done David
take it and go I'm sorry so sorry I let
you fall it's all right you made the
right choice
Maggie knew you wouldn't make the right
choice huh
my wife she knew in her note she wrote
that she knows you'll make the right
choice when the time comes the note was
for me with that section that line that
was for you I know it I see it
Oh get up please in a sec okay kid
uncle Barry's gotta rest his bones a bit
go David get good care of him okay
I don't know what you're going but I'll
meet you in another life goodbye Barry
maybe Cody could have made it
he's spry he's a spry kid he could've
made
he's a spry him that sucks
poor Barry I have to leave him like this
for now maybe after finding again it's
it there will be time to honor him
oh the Dunas sand on the other side I
better find another exit nothing usual
here kalam Klump
no no oh I've unlocked it great great
Kate David you've got the location you
really don't care about Barry do you
don't you want to ask about him first I
just assumed he's dead he died for this
information Cade he died for God's sake
like I said that's what I assumed
okay soom I've got your stupid map then
show me it take a look the launch pad is
here in the mountains you can go right
away what about your dream the bandits
Raiders what about them if we get to the
launch pad fast they won't be our
problem I don't own David you had that
dream I mean we Mo's escaped them just
like that if the ship is still there
might require a lot of work before it
takes off those thugs follow us there
they can't find out about the ship we
have to deal with them first we have to
stay one more night
you realize you're putting our lives at
risk they have guns
we can't lead them to that ship so what
do you think of this place I was
expecting something more to tell the
truth I heard so many things about this
place but I never made it here myself
until now of course Hugh City the bigger
they are boy any ideas for today the
best defense is a good offense what what
me we won't have any chance we need to
go to their camp and do as much possible
to stop them a little sabotage won't
hurt actually maybe it will will hurt
them that's the point just make sure we
don't get spotted we wouldn't stand a
chance in an open fight like that poor
Barry yes yes it's all you have to say I
regret he died I wish he had was that so
difficult to say this is exactly why I
don't want to get attached losing
friends is difficult losing strangers
not familiar I can handle it almost too
easily so do me a favor in mourning for
the both of us
please anything new on Cody what do you
mean he's not that annoying profess what
you're asking no I didn't mean that I
told you already I think he's a poor kid
I was expecting him to be into the
obstacle but for now he's doing well
enough I'm pretty sure he's afraid of me
maybe that's for the best
at least he'll listen to someone you
think he wouldn't listen to me David
please Mayweather Kathryn Mayweather huh
is that your name why do you ask
I've seen it in one of the documents you
worked for SideReel didn't you briefly I
didn't even know where this office was
before I had the dream I just had
and I definitely wasn't important enough
to earn my place on the lifeboat it
appears alright why hide it
why conceal that information isn't an
obvious David sidereal caused it all of
it the moon yes and more than that I
wasn't directly involved but you can
imagine oh you can imagine I don't want
to be shot in the face by a stranger for
mentioning that my employers
accidentally destroyed the world what
else are you hiding nothing geez David
I'm sorry but I think you know more than
you say that turned out to be the truth
in the past and I think it's still the
case all right you don't have to trust
me if you don't want to just help me get
to that ship where do those dreams come
from oh the ship is gone so from the
documents I found it seems people from
this office were evacuated to the launch
pad wouldn't that mean the ship is long
gone it's not gone how do you know
dreams David I also keep having them
where do you think those dreams come
from how is it even possible I believe
those are visions sent by someone I
think you're crazy if I didn't have the
same thoughts myself maybe we're both
crazy then well that's always possible
I'll be back
I'm sure you will come with me I need
your help with something very um I'm
sorry David poor man yeah
poor man God what if it was Kody jeez
I'm so sad I couldn't do that
Oh what Barry wanted I guess it's fine
then if you want you could save some
time and build a simple grave for your
friend this reaction would take 30
minutes yeah come on we have to go
farewell friend goodbye Barry he sleeps
calmly watching the blue sky through the
hole in the ceiling above him but there
was one more thing that I could use
people's help on if they wouldn't mind
climbing up a whose hey get over here
with your big strong muscles me not
strong you
you big strong who bad strong can you
help with pipe plays terrifying and
dangerous oh come on I mean it remember
what happened on the roof let's not stay
any longer then how about that we have
things to do okay but could you help me
with the pipe could could you help me
with the with the pipe help with pipe
maybe only Barry could have helped with
the pipe ah all right whatever
it's ply not that important because only
Cody would have been able to go through
the vent and then maybe only Barry could
have gone through there and you have to
somehow save both of them who knows okay
let's get you out of here we gotta go
let's just go right Pat I don't want to
see the grave we're just getting out
here we're going going we're going and
just I didn't know that there was a
sighs wait was this wait a minute hang
on a second hold on a tick Declan second
here hold on tickling second hang on a
second wait I just have to see something
I just got to see something I'm just
gonna look at something and then I'm
gonna shave mmm oh my god this was here
wait a minute wait a minute wait wait a
minute
seems to be locked from the other side
wait a minute wait hang on hang on a
second
it's no use the lock is too strong all
right okay there's nothing to be done I
guess let's go home first I got to drop
some crap off oh gottoms mmm-hmm there's
gotta be way I know there's gotta be
some way like maybe a few new game+ it
and it's like you have all this
information that you wouldn't ordinarily
wait face control light wait a minute
wait wait hang on wait stop everybody
stop hang on let's go back here uh hey
I'll be right back okay so I got this on
I'm gonna use this floppy disk on this
PC right huh reading disk err this disk
has been encrypted and will only work on
a designated workstation Flo's worth a
try I've taken the disk back okay at
least I tried that okay at least I tried
that okay I'm gonna go back to
oh did I not save when I was do all why
didn't I say when I was we're gonna
leave I'm done with this we got to get
out of here we're gonna get in the car
we're gonna go back home cuz we got to
drop some [ __ ] off no good here they're
everywhere
bada bing bada boom bada bing okay and
put the rat poison away that may be the
rat poison maybe they could help
sabotage something the silencer keep the
keep in no matter what okay I'll keep it
on me the rock that who needs it maybe
distraction I don't know um we're gonna
call this a day for now okay we're gonna
go back here we're gonna go check out
this hunting lodge all right let's get
yeah let's get going all right
ooh all right well let's check the
outside first before we're going
anywhere oh oh what a terrible stink is
it the outhouse or is the animal carcass
it's crawling with maggots I think I'm
gonna throw up
Oh should I hold your hand damn it Kate
this is sickening yuck it smells like I
don't know horse scent anything all
right it stings like hell I'll give you
that move the corpse and prepare the
trap for another use uh yeah we're gonna
need him right now I smell no better
than dead boar your bear trap
all right a bear trap bear trap easy
enough okay that's good that's gonna
help Kate what do you think of this
place it's not that great could be
easily compromised or is gone even if we
secure the windows it would still be
easy to get inside you always have to
give me those tactical explanations what
else you want from me I'm never say how
I feel not who know my therapist Hey
all right Cody what do you think of this
place Oh what's wrong Cody I don't like
this place the trees here look scary I
think I saw a monster over there
monsters don't exist you don't have to
worry about that I still don't like it I
always wanted to have a cat but we
couldn't have animals in the orphanage
we had a hamster once but yeah the boys
didn't take care of it people didn't
seem to take care of animals either
there's always reason behind everything
what is it Cody you said there are
bandits can we just talk to them they're
bad people Cody they won't listen I
chatted with you yesterday even though
you could have been him evil I wish it
was that simple
maybe believe some of them Cody maybe
maybe are you old enough kid I miss
Barry he was so kind and good
did he fell in a hole Shh don't cry
I'm not crying just don't cry stop dude
no don't ask in here uh this looks gross
enough time to sit down the painting
depicts a wolf or a large dog in a snowy
hill there's a human settlement in the
distance night is dark in the sky seems
hazy I think I've seen this picture
somewhere before no idea where so what
do we got I've been thinking and I still
don't get it
what no you why are you so mean to David
sometimes oh I thought we covered that
cuz he's a dork I thought it was
goof-goof
right well that's that but that's why I
don't get it wasn't he like that before
before what before you and him got
married yes he was a goof why would you
marry him I wouldn't marry him wink wink
wink wink wink wink then did he like
make you marry him Why What
that's what villains do did he pretend
to be different or did he threaten you
kid listen you're when a man and a woman
love each other very much I'm getting a
nasty headache just the thoughts of
being married go doll me mark I forgot I
was replacing the name with mark the
fireplace is empty with a thick layer of
ash on its walls and floors it smells
like burnt wood one of those antlers is
skewed I can't reach it
why would I want to fix it can I poke it
with a shovel you shovel on hunters
trophy it seems long enough to be able
to push the antler there there was a
loud click somewhere in the room
ah and where in the room would that have
been
ah what about in here
anything bear trap it's too heavy I have
to put something down first okay let me
load up the car real quick can you guys
stop being lazy and carry something for
once okay what do we got here workbench
of some kind we got a bottle of whiskey
maybe get the guys drunk riflescope
that's handy sake won't solve any of our
problems well anything to plug in okay
so what went click clunk what clunks
scratches oh there are some visible
scratches on the floor as if something
was pushed back and forth repeatedly
[Laughter]
there was a revolver in the safe there's
still something there what do we got
there was a box of rifle ammo in the
safe there's one more box inside there
was a box or revolver ammo in the safe
the safe is empty are you sure you sure
about that oh no you sure okay so I
don't know if that was everything in
here but that's a lot of goodies good
get a gun that's a rifle scope and a
rifle silencer we got a bob some pops of
rifle rounds box of handgun rounds so
that's good um we got another one of
these bad boys and I think we're good
why do we have kitchen oil though we got
oil let me just double-check it I got
everything here I'll save before I leave
that's a good haul for now let's go here
all right let's hop in the car and we
can't make it down to that way but where
would we find the bandits is the
question because if we were trying to
mess with the bandits the only way we'd
be able to do that is if we actually
found where their base was so maybe the
roadblock would have something maybe up
by the car wrecks something new happen
here nah still same ol same ol
yeah let's scrap by the RV maybe there's
something that's leading because
otherwise I'm not a hundred percent sure
what we would need to do I've removed
the hook from the crap that route might
be useful elsewhere wait wait a minute I
just had a thought
you don't think wait you don't think do
you do you
I don't know if you think you you
wouldn't think would you you I'll be
right back
okay it did not work you couldn't use
the rope to go down and save one of them
quicker or anything like that so that's
a big old no Peas on that one so we are
left with no one beside us just to try
to prepare for the inevitable there's
really nowhere else to go in the map and
I don't know where the bandits would be
coming from so I guess we just start
preparing my guess yeah it only carries
so many of these at a time but yeah I
guess if I just start laying him out
best idea I would have would be to like
put them by the doors so that if they
get in there you know it's like I don't
want them to see them coming so I don't
know man
it's all a mystery at this point so I
only have two sets of nails
I need more nails eventually I'm not
100% sure where I'm gonna get more nails
but I do need more nails daddy's a good
Quast all right let me go ahead and
combine these oh [ __ ] that takes a lot
of time but I do need a lot of time to
get this stuff set up I'm out of nails
to get from there but I think there are
places where I can go get nails out of
stuff that I've already broken because I
think I'm fully there's not a no nails
left yeah no nails left or as far as
wood goes this is really not gonna help
me as I'll just drop them on the ground
I mean I don't know what else I'm
supposed to do I feel like if we go back
to a certain place we're eventually
gonna find some kind of answer Oh while
you're traveling past the gas station
you saw some movement around the area
from a distance you want to investigate
yes yes I do
stop shut up and stick to the plan you
hear that guys yeah somebody's talking
they won't catch much from here we could
sneak to the shop and listen from there
and that's why I'm not sure if it's a
good idea you're a coward and a
fartknocker Sarge
we need their supply so we're gonna take
their crib is totally though amazing
defensive spot for us to use my politics
are there this is gonna be a good
defensive part for us it is a good
metaphor for them yeah track me up
we've been watching them for some time
now it's just two dudes a chick that a
freakin rat one trifle a happy family
plus a blaze uncle and there's freaking
plenty of us there including your army
boy scout yeah oh yeah right damn right
I am
I want your men to be ready at dusk I've
welcomed you into the gang what it's
time to start paying off scars yeah I
are already we're heading back to the
construction site to tell the boys the
plan construction site you talking about
I've seen one back in the helicopter
I'll mark it on your map maybe we'll
visit later do come in the fuel tankers
I have another lawyer the guy's a okay
catch you later pal jerk ah so we should
talk to this guy yeah we should probably
talk to this guy I'll say before I talk
to this guy but we should definitely
talk to this guy definitively definitely
let's talk this guy are you guys you
stay here I might need your help in case
there's trouble have you know what
you're doing
give me one good reason not to unload
the whole clip in your face I better be
a damn good reason I could have killed
you I want to negotiate I could have
killed you I saw you talking with the
rest of your gang then you turned your
back to me and I could have killed you
easily what you did what exactly
violence does that currently give you
what I mean is I didn't shoot you
because I thought we could have a
civilized talk civilized talk look
around you son my stuff dude I didn't
know he was gonna be an actual character
look around you son how much of a
civilization do you see rounder yourself
huh exactly I'll tell you what your
attitude amuses me
we can talk people that were with you
cause you Sarge are you really a
sergeant
I used to be sergeant first class to be
specific but that doesn't matter anymore
it's in the past it's all in the past
now
my nickname is all I have from that life
that guy the bike mentioned something
about your men is your squad Jesus
you've been listening to all that well
yeah it's my squad all right what's left
of it for men they still take orders
from me even if we're no soldiers
anymore
who's the guy you would talk to a :
raise war he is the leader of the gang
and technically my boss also a guy that
will most likely kill you I would avoid
him at all costs if I were you so why
did you join him are you kidding me is
if I had a choice we were alone me and
what was left of my squad there's no
more army no HQ no government we have
nowhere to go no supplies no food no
shelter raise war took a sin in exchange
for our muscles even if I'm not proud of
it okay well so that's all for now I
think from now on we shooting each other
next I was hoping that could be avoided
just go away and I'll pretend I haven't
seen you okay all right okay cool see
you later bud well that was interesting
Kate hey what about this guy what are
you looking at me like that I'm just
wondering why you let that guy live it
would be easier to deal with them one by
one
I'm not some cold-blooded murderer you
realize that we're living in times when
it's us or them right it's not some
fairy tale with a happy ending stop
acting like a child David grow up I'll
be back I'm sure you will
hey there squirt are you worried about
something no I'm fine well yeah maybe a
little if it's about that soldier you
don't have to be worried he looked like
a good guy I'm pretty sure I can
recognize a villain I read a lot of
comic books good to have the specialists
in the field
oh yeah the construction site okay let's
go down here and see what is up Oh
Scouts that's no good Paul I shouldn't
just wander right up to it Kate yeah any
thoughts we've got to be really careful
this place seems to be swarming with
those guys I'm sure if I walk up to him
I'm gonna get shat so I'm gonna just
save a little bit just a little bit just
a wee bit hey buddies the entrance is
guarded who would have thought well
going there would be suicide let's go
there
alright whatever fine you big baby I can
sneak through there maybe they won't
notice guys you better stay here are you
sure there's a good idea no but it might
work maybe there's a back door somewhere
alright even if you sneak past the
guards even if you find a way in what
exactly do you would intend to do
you're not exactly a special task
force's type I'm just gonna look around
maybe I'll find something useful don't
get yourself shot please be careful okay
I promise I'll be back soon
ooh it's a sneaky whoa
don't mind the Boyd Oh God why did I get
this oh why did I do this go now well
that didn't work
okay so what do I do with this what is
it what is the point of this that magnet
could be used to distract the guard but
not directly maggots don't randomly fall
from the sky it would just make it more
alert if anything sure okay all right
then
um fence shelf what is that oh oh that
was just a matter of finding the right
spot okay that's better okay good good
it's raised or okay food supplies oh
yeah ham boxes we it's a bit upsetting
to think all these bullets will be
flying in my general direction a few
hours from now
food supplies what have you got I've
taken some food all right
already taken some food I don't want
them to notice what about that don't I
want that okay all right well hey listen
buddy I don't think getting near those
guys is a good idea um rat poison wait
no hang on
maybe that's not the best idea in the
world is it that seems like a good idea
don't it don't it after you poison the
food it will no longer be safe to eat
looking at the warning of the poison
level some thugs might expect nausea
internal bleeding liver failure or death
you cannot undo this action sometimes
you have to do what you have to do to
survive on the other hand are you this
kind of person oh I don't know I I don't
I don't know maybe I could sabotage the
oh I don't know keep away from fire keep
dry
keep dry where could I get water
interesting so I can poison their food
supply and then I could either burn oh
if I had my gas that's what I could do
I'm running he's distracted oh good I
think I've got the the gas in here what
if I burn it I mean it would cook off
immediately probably but I don't know if
there's any place that I could get water
okay so if I pour bad idea well you
don't know it's a bad idea come on
you've got to down that food with
something right oh oh oh that's a much
nicer way to do it uh-huh
I don't know if I should be nice but
okay sure I don't know where I'm gonna
get water though okay let's get out of
here I think I used up all my bottles of
water I mean that whiskey's got to be
good enough right I have no idea oh
hello everybody
hey you again okay never mind you mind
if I grab some more gas I kind of need
it you mind if I just grab a little
while your your mind
don't wait sorry I'm dumb I forgot that
didn't put a can down don't mind me I'm
quite stupid I forgot okay so I know I
don't have everything I'm well aware
that I do not have everything I need but
I'm I'm just curious as to what if I can
conglomerating I have I'm gonna get this
together I'm gonna get this together I'm
going to close the door I'm gonna lock
the door where did I put it put it in
the truck did I put the keys in the
truck I did didn't I I'm so stupid
okay so I've only got two sets of this
which is unfortunate but I think yeah
what if we're in the whatever in the
sealing compartment there's a hatch oh
[ __ ] hello hatch Oh what the [ __ ] I
didn't know this was up here how long
has this been up here what the [ __ ] what
is it with this new area Oh chiminey
chim chiminey chim chiminey true seems
chimney is clogged by something inside I
can't reach it
um that wouldn't work why wouldn't that
work what are you gonna reach what what
you can't reach it
maybe I could Oh
use the rope I guess maybe what I didn't
this is new to me
okay all right then rope let's take you
out let's put you back in for now do the
rope thing actually let's make some
space here there because now suddenly we
have another mission that we're trying
to accomplish what else do I have this
long yeah there we go a dead bird that's
what I got a dead bird okay oh that's if
I needed to use the chimney oh okay
alright then alright well that doesn't
help anybody okay yeah I know I way off
the mark in terms of preparation but I
just want to see what's gonna happen cuz
I want I want to get an idea of how much
more I need I might give the gun to Kate
you might need this thanks I already
have a gun remember right okay Cody
listened you're gonna get a gun tell me
her him butter bag give her Cody
revolver that was a plan
well I'm not sure if there's a
responsible behaviour I want a gun he
has to be able to defend himself Kate
yeah but can you actually even use it I
know where the triggers I've seen enough
action movies that's not really enough
to be able to defend yourself Cody but
I'll teach you you still have that can I
give you at the restaurant
yes but it's empty that's okay well we
need is an empty camp we'll use it for
target practice
put it over there and come back yeah
let's teach him there those are the
basics did I do well yeah you just have
to be really careful hey what did I do
something wrong no it's just I really
don't want you to have to get involved
in a fight I'm not making you a soldier
feels like you kinda are David okay well
here have some ammo
no bad idea alright well alright let me
just gonna see here we go
a group of raiders commanded by a name
named rays or arrived at dusk they
weren't trying to hide circling your
hideout with their bikes engines roaring
horses screaming your time for slaughter
has come piglets
that will be your wolf some of his gang
was missing two thugs found a fine
bottle of whiskey in their supplies how
can you say no to an opportunity like
that we were too drunk to move out and
we're left to sober up missile party
okay the attackers opened fire bullets
swoosh through the air some flew far
closest your head
the walls sitting in the upstairs window
armed with a sniper rifle you fired at
the attackers with a view enhanced by a
scope you managed to get five of them
sending them to the dusty dirt they
didn't get up afterwards keeping some
extra Meniere's after all even if it was
an accidental without extra ammo you
managed to shoot one more thug as he was
nearing the house closed door and locked
the front door
solid metal stars while they were
forcing their way in two of them
Cody was nervously looking at the
revolver that gun was big but in his
case looked huge couldn't accept by the
fact that he was killed by a kid
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay so I was way way way off which is
fine because I assumed I was anyway real
sad the bear traps did nothing why did
the bear traps do nothing because they
weren't outside and covered or something
like that maybe they need to be covered
let me try hang on I got an idea okay so
if I drop a bear trap right here and
then I like try to cover it with you
know cuz it didn't say a thing about the
bear traps I just don't think they're
very cleverly hidden oh that makes sense
I gave him everything except the monkey
wrench just a little bit ago come on
you'll never open the valve with your
bare hands he's been sitting here for
six hours trying to open this with his
bare hands
I literally went up next to him with the
monkey wrench the game should at that
point be like oh nice monkey wrench you
got you want to give me your all right
why do you even help me because I feel
it's the right thing to do oh thanks
alright nice gun you got there why'd you
have to pull that out on me okay you
again are we talking now okay help got
enough fuel yeah thanks for your help I
guess no problem I guess this is how it
should be we don't have to fight you
know there is no need for violence we
can all live in peace
can we I'm not sure there was a kid with
me Cody he's 10 or something he doesn't
have to go through this oh but he does
he very much has to go through this we
all go through this
nobody ever asks us I had a son you know
do you think anyone asked me for an
opinion when panicking crowd trampled my
poor boy into a mass sack of broken
bones I I'm so sorry yeah I'm sorry too
I was supposed to protect those people
when they tried to evacuate and I
couldn't even protect my boy so no the
fact that you have a kid on your happy
team doesn't give you a golden ticket of
mercy not for me at least all right dick
the moon is falling on our heads yeah
Wow I didn't notice maybe I was too busy
trying to look after myself and my squad
because the damn moon exploded and is
falling on us what I meant was it's
gonna crash into Earth like really soon
good good it's all gonna end it has to
this whole nightmare let me tell you a
story okay oh boy our squad was helping
with evacuation we were on a chopper
hovering above a football stadium where
people were had gathered we were picking
up the wounded to get them to safety
suddenly BAM another earthquake started
and everything went to hell literally
the ground split open burst and now red
flames do you know the Bible I'm not an
expert I wasn't a religious man either
but I have to seeing all this I have to
see in a whole stadium of people being
swallowed by Hell itself in one chomp it
was then that I realized there is no
hope nothing is gonna end well this is
Judgment Day the final chapter of
mankind we have they might have a clue
to where to find a spaceship yeah would
you need that for to escape to escape
you're out of your mind where would you
escape well there's a Space Station
supposedly son I understand you want to
survive at all cost but this being
delusional the entire world is dead this
isn't something you just escaped from
you can't there's nowhere to go there is
no magical kingdom no wonderful utopia
waiting for survivors no Space Station
will save you don't let anyone fool you
like that I still think there's got to
be another way we don't have to kill
each other I doubt that you were a
soldier a man of honor I can't believe
someone like you would sign up for a
slaughter of innocent people the times
have changed son I've changed nothing is
as it used to be on a won't feed you it
won't give you shelter the times have
changed and so did we to survive
the times are not just changing the
times are coming to an end these are the
final days can't you see we'll all be
over soon
maybe yet we still bother we're not all
pulling bullets to our heads we still
fight to survive yes we're still trying
to survive against all odds still we're
most likely all going to die but time is
running out and here we are standing in
the wasteland with our hands close to
our guns preparing to fight like a bunch
of idiots what do you suggest we do then
let us go let us go the house is yours
with all the supplies if it was that
simple I would let you go believe me I
would but it's not that simple
you can leave the raise all will follow
you and hunt you down because you're
more than just an obstacle for him you
are his prey
oh ok well let's try this again you're a
soldier man you be ran your new moon you
should go what are you kidding you don't
like when we're working for raise or you
know respect race or you don't like him
you only work for him because your squad
is counting on you
but this is not the right way and deep
down you know I'm right
razor won't save you from the end the
question is what kind of man are you
gonna be when the end comes what do you
want to see in the eyes of your squad
you're right there is no point in to
none it I'll talk to my squad we'll
change our ways while we still can
oh thanks oh it's that easy huh ok
alright see ya I guess this is goodbye
then take my squad and leave right
before disk make no mistake
Rizal was still trying to get you so
you'll have to deal with the rest of his
men how many people we have without us
he's down to 15 still that's a hell a
lot more than you might have good luck
soon you'll need it hey Sarge
Martin Thanks good luck out there in the
wasteland I mean you're gonna die when
the moon comes go boom but you know
that's it ok alright so that's 15 that's
good so oh god I'm almost out of fuel um
good I bring the kid did I did I go
alright so I didn't bring that because
I'm an idiot ok wasting time I've got
like no time left
can I don't know why I didn't bring it
is there anything else I need okay I
don't know I don't know I've got that
there's got to be one last thing I can
do at the camp they had three hours and
18 minutes I've never actually gotten
close to running out of time I've also
already got some prep work done for the
journey over so I'm gonna figure out
what the hell to do because I know I
know there's something to do with that
ammo I know it says very specifically
keep away from fire keep dry the easiest
thing that I would think would just be
to dump gasoline on it cuz that does
both things in both wet ins it and then
it also could make it cook if they were
to try to fire it like to me that's a
logical thing you know what I mean I
feel uh how many were left there were
nine left so really I'm close I just
need four more kills if the bear traps
work like maybe I need to put him
outside instead of inside but I don't
think that inside would make sense to do
the oil I mean that's no different than
gasoline I guess there's no other reason
for it so vodkas contain a lot of
different kinds of bullets both are far
too heavy or clunky to move i've porta
I have a canister of gasoline that
wouldn't be better it's fine it's fine
it's fine you know it it's fine okay
with that I think if there's that and
then I go home I put the bear traps like
this maybe there's a way I got food
maybe I can use that to like cover
something I don't know only and I gotta
empty my inventory a little bit because
I'm full up I'll get right by the window
I'll put two out front and I'll go in
here we're gonna lock this bad boy right
up lucky lucky we're gonna go out back
we're gonna put two bear traps right one
on the door and one right here oh yeah
baby okay
two bear traps are ready to go
luckylucky get the I left the ammo in
the truck no no I don't know I always
get frustrated towards the end because
it's like it's like that point where
I've been wandering around so long and
now that I know what to do it's like oh
okay I get it now III understand the
necessity of the situation so I'm gonna
do that there we go okay and now
everything should be good and it should
work perfectly right right this day is
taking so long
but I was getting back into the swing of
things so I think we can wait it out now
I got my gun okay a grouper Raiders
commanded by a man named Rees or arrived
by dusk if we're trying to hide circling
your hideout screaming your time for
slaughter has come piglets and I will be
whoa somebody's gang was missing two
thugs found a fine bottle of whiskey
they were too drunk when the bandits
moved out from their base of small
groups split off from them win the
opposite direction Sarge wasn't brave
enough to confront rays or but he
thought things through sufficiently he
and his four men never showed up to
attack you 30 men including razor and
close-in to attack the attackers opened
fire bullets swoosh through the air some
flew far too close to your head
decorating the walls of house with
numerous small holes some of the guns
didn't spit out any deadly protect those
with a dry click they refused to work
properly
- someone meddle with their ammo supply
three the attackers found themselves
unarmed and had to retreat before the
attack even truly started good sitting
in the window armed with a sniper rifle
you
the attackers with a view enhanced by a
scope you managed to hit four of them
sending them to the dusty dirt they
didn't get up keeping Symmetra ammo I
managed to shoot one more thug near in
the house before dusk here we go out of
the fort rafts three caught razors men
hurt and unable to proceed they
retreated happy to be live you closed
and locked the front door you close and
lock the back door you put solid metal
bars on the ground floor window while
they were forcing the rain Kate shot one
of them with cold blood after that she
had her treat upstairs as the entry was
breached
Cody was nervously looking at the
revolver in his hand he aimed and pull
the trigger trying not to look away and
no [ __ ] killed rays or oh [ __ ] wait
no oh was my incoming punch oh [ __ ] oh
cool
the fight was tough but with the
tactical advantage of your hideout and
proper preparation you managed to defeat
them all with just minor wounds on your
wait no no no wait hang on hold on a
second where no wait no stop that's not
right that's not what me live for that's
no that's no good that's not that's no
good that's no you think you can just
come to my house and [ __ ] all over my
face like this do you think you can just
do that you think you can enter my house
with your guns and your ammo and your
fancy whatever's and you're screaming
with your megaphone you think you can do
that and you think I would just let you
get away with such an act you you think
that I would just let this happen you
think I would not take action against
such a thing as that you you think that
I would do that
well the answer is where is that last
nail that I know exists I know you exist
nail oh I already Bardo
why was that not a perfect score I don't
I don't put the rat poison and it was
very clear about that what did I miss
I had this perfect everything was
perfect everything was fine
everything was great what about this guy
oh maybe I should distract him first
okay all right there we go I'm a brutal
murderer I'm a Buddha Moya okay that's
one that was one more death and not the
nicest thing admittedly
admittedly not the nicest thing to do
but that's one more and I think he
that's I just needed that one more I
think I think he that gonna give me we
fix Scully I don't know if that was like
a good idea to do but whatever just in
case I need to redo all of day three I'm
gonna save at number two now okay all
right let's try this again okay your
time is comment oh yeah there goes the
one down okay okay good idea for left
one closed door locked front razor
himself was trying to force his way into
your hideout gates simply open the door
and put it her gun to his head you
managed to repel for the evening on your
house that was a terrifying performance
on your side who would have thought
you're such an efficient killer you
prepared your hideout perfectly and it
paid off not only did you survive but
you also had some good rest last night
slept like a baby yes yes your ass what
are we facing what have we got what is
it what is it now what are we doing what
let me look out the window stick my face
right out there get a good smell a cold
night outside okay holy [ __ ] I'm awake
where is everybody well so that is it
for day 3 of don't escape for thank you
everybody so much for watching look
forward to the next episode as soon as I
am able we start filming the big
projects out here in Austin Monday I
don't know when you guys are gonna see
this video but it started Monday so
thank
everybody so much for watching we're
gonna finish this up in just one more
episode and as always see you in the
next video
[Music]